let me ask you the question of
legalization so
should in your view all drugs be
legalized
the drugs that people seek certainly
should be legally regulated and
available to adults so when i say the
drugs people seek like cannabis mdma
cocaine heroin um
those drugs certainly should be
available and some of the psychedelics
that people seek
now the thing about it is that
some people uh
think that oh we'll be a free fall these
drugs are available to everyone that's
not true i mean it would be there will
be age requirements and maybe other
requirements but they should be
available and we should also do like
what we do with alcohol we can put
enough alcohol in a bottle to kill you
but we don't so we regulate it such that
the amount that's in the bottle enhances
the safety and minimizes the potential
harms
we can do the same thing with these
other drugs and we can also
say okay we won't be selling intravenous
preparations of any of these drugs these
the drugs that the routes of
administration will be oral and i don't
know let's say uh
uh intranasal um
again routes of administration to dose
that you have in each unit
all can minimize harm based on how you
do these things and we can do that we
have the technology we have the know-how
so you're actually making me think about
alcohol a little bit so if i were say
the drugs become legalized in the way
you're describing and me
lex wanted to
as an adult explore some of these drugs
what are some procedures do you think uh
for sort of safe
positive exploration of those drugs
the reason i say i'm thinking about
alcohol because i don't think
besides not putting enough alcohol in a
bottle to kill you
i don't think anyone ever gave me
specific instructions i think it's kind
of word of mouth and examples of people
doing the wrong thing you kind of get it
through osmosis that way yeah
is that basically what we would do this
kind of free exploration of use no we
have to change our education about these
things i mean
um let's just take a drug like cocaine
cocaine is a stimulant
and you want to make sure people
understand that they shouldn't be taking
cocaine their bedtime and you know they
need to get a certain amount of
hours of sleep
and um they need to get up in the
morning cocaine probably isn't a drug
for you at night certainly not
um certainly not amphetamines at night
for most people and also if you want to
make sure that you they need to
understand that cocaine uh can also
disrupt your food intake not as much as
the amphetamines but all of these kind
of things people need to know so they
can have
proper nutrition and they can
time their drug use around these other
important functions that's the same
human night so we have to make sure that
we
educate people we can't just
throw people in a while that's stupid
i gotta tell you i mean for me
and even given your book and for people
listening to this it's still
it's still tough to hear that the thing
we should be concerned about with
cocaine
is the same as with caffeine
don't take it before bed and the thing
which would be concerned with heroin
is constipation yeah
okay
but the questions i keep wanting to ask
you
i should be asking the same things of
alcohol
but when you're not doing well
psychologically in the ways you describe
when the environment is not right
there's some aspect in which saying that
drugs can be used responsibly and
effectively and mostly positive
can uh give those folks a pass
to use it instead of working on
themselves and fixing their environment
first
i i don't know what what do you want me
to say to that i mean they have access
to alcohol they have access to them um
you know we live in this country called
the united states where our declaration
of independence says that
we are free to live like we want to live
so long as we don't
disrupt other people from doing the same
but it's remarkable to me how we try to
control the behaviors of other people
that's just
remarkable
yeah
and that's partially what your book is
about i mean it's not just about drugs
it's about freedom that's the bigger
issue that we can't get to it's like
this issue of freedom and freedom comes
with a tremendous amount of
responsibility i am responsible for my
neighbors my brothers i mean
i can't
impede their freedoms like some people
think that their freedom supersedes
everybody else's freedoms no and that's
what i'm trying to remind people in this
book
i am
uh responsible to you um as a citizen um
and
we're in this together
and i tried to make that point in the
book and people
have conveniently ignored things like
that
you